we have breaking news from Washington
where President Trump has fired
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson and the
move has been in the works since last
year but a State Department official
says the president did not explain his
decision to Tillerson in fact Tillerson
only heard about his firing when it was
made public where it is he heard it on
Twitter the president tweeted this just
over an hour ago Mike Pompeo director of
the CIA will become our new Secretary of
State he will do a fantastic job thank
you to Rex Tillerson for his service the
president says he will name Jena Haspel
Pompeo s deputy to head the CIA she
would be the first woman to ever be
director major Garrett is at the White
House where the president spoke about
his decision major good morning good
morning the estrangement between Rex
Tillerson the Secretary of State and
President Trump has long known here in
Washington they simply did not get along
personally and they disagreed on
significant foreign policy matters North
Korea most recently also Russia Syria
and the Iran nuclear deal and as
president Trump left the White House
earlier this morning heading for marine
one and a trip to California he talked
to reporters and explained just how
difficult his relationship with
Tillerson had become and that this has
been an issue the two had been
discussing for some time let's take a
listen Rex and I have been talking about
this for a long time we we've got along
actually quite well but we disagreed on
things when you look at the Iran deal I
think it's terrible I guess he fit it
was okay I wanted to either break it or
do something and he felt a little bit
differently so we were not really
thinking the same I asked the president
during that encounter with reporters if
North Korea was also an issue he said he
made the decision which surprised many
here at the White House last week to
agree to a meeting with Kim jong-un the
North Korean dictator and that Rex
Tillerson really wasn't a part of that
conversation that kind of estrangement
between diplomacy and the president's
own initiatives part of this difficult
relationship Mike Pompeo the person who
provides the president his daily
intelligence briefing and has a close
working relationship with him may in
fact be more empowered at Secretary of
State if in fact he's confirmed as the
expects John Major Thanks